it's a case where being number one means
really your number to a new study ranks
California dead last of all the states
in quality of life making it tops at
being on the bottom states were ranked
on everything from education to
opportunity from infrastructure to crime
but California scored low for one simple
reason it's impossible to live there
unless you are super rich or homeless
then come one come all but just ask any
u-haul dealer renting a truck to go from
San Francisco to Dallas will cost thirty
two hundred bucks the return trip only
eleven hundred that's a one hundred and
eighty percent surcharge and it's based
on a truck shortage in California
because so many people are leaving one
left-wing city to a more pragmatic
affordable one
so maybe Californians leaving California
they're the real dreamers but anyone
who's been to LA knows the ugly truth
it's turned into a post-apocalyptic
wasteland with 55,000 homeless in that
county alone massive encampments have an
enveloped Skid Row under overpasses and
streets nearby SF isn't much better
spending millions last year on cleaning
up human waste left on its streets by
the homeless
it's odd we're living at a time where
Hollywood embraces dystopian fiction
they spend millions trying to recreate
the look of life after nuclear war I
could save them some money just grab an
iPhone and drive downtown alright I'm
gonna go do you want I never got to you
first so I thought it might be a time to
ask this question if the Lord California
has like the largest percentage of poor
yet massive government services what
does that tell you what does that tell
you that's Sarah that they're meeting
the needs of the people no it's that
they're not even with no matter how much
money they have I think they have a huge
homeless population and the government
spends a lot of money dealing with and
you have villages well here's the thing
you know one I think that the real
reason they ranked at the bottom right
is lack of human interaction from what I
read I read that too okay so I'm just
saying I think that you were on target
and saying it's like they're rich you
can live a fabulous life in California
but if you're not rich then your rent is
too high people don't interact and it's
not a commune
everybody's driving everybody's into
their own private space so to me I
understand what you're saying but I had
a question for you no questions for
conservatives delighting in California
being ranked as the word oh no I'm not
because well no I think we like to be
proven correct oh that when you see
massive liberal bureaucracies fail we go
why didn't you listen to us I'm sad that
I have to leave California I'm from
there Jesse so you have income
inequality you have pollution and
segregated neighborhoods what have
Republicans done to this guy oh wait no
it's run by Democrats all the things the
Kratt say they're against they're just
doing it in their own state yeah I've
been to skid row it was the scariest
moment of my life you know I've been to
every single neighborhood south side of
Chicago I've been to Detroit everything
I did not leave the car because they
said it was so unsafe that was a white
guys with expensive cameras walked
outside into these encampments it's
honestly like Armageddon it's
post-apocalyptic you have zombies on
drugs wandering around there's needles
everywhere there's no law enforcement
it's lawless it's chaos it's dirty it's
infested with disease it's the place on
earth you'd think it was in a
third-world country it's right next to
City Hall yes and they tolerate it
ironically if you've been with Skid Row
concert it's actually enjoyable
Kimberley Bay Area sad you're from the
Bay Area just go born and raised in San
Francisco so I'm a native yeah it's very
sad I think what's gone on there because
now because they think with is the
liberal politics that this is what love
should look like that you trust your
city that you allow anything goes that
you have sanctuary cities you let the
citizens get murdered there's total
lawlessness and no public safety who's
gonna be the next governor friendliness
I think Kevin Newsome I mean you know
he's in a tight race with Antonio there
we go so we'll see so it's gonna be the
battle and I know he's not your he's not
a typical liberal but he was good when
he was mayor of Terrence's I was there
although the economy there is terrific
right some people wanna know I'm just
saying it's like I think it's like the
fourth best economy and then what you
got you got Silicon Valley
I want to get Dana in California but in
a different place I lived in San Diego
for three years beautiful city 99 well
99 yet till I went back to the Justice
Department in 2001 after 9/11 and San
Diego's been run by conservatives and
Republicans for most of its the
Catholics the county has I wouldn't say
that necessarily about the mayor though
the mayor is a Republican Kevin I
believe he's still calls himself hello
but you know what's interesting
Democrats will say that Eric Garcetti
the current mayor of Los Angeles they
talk about him as a realistic candidate
for president in 2020 Wow he's very nice
I worked for his father a gil garcetti
and I spent a lot of time um at the
family's house and I love Dana
oh my fans are yes what's the small
world isn't it do you know anybody else
I gotta go